the first proposition that they make is
that we should treat the reality that
we're dealing with as psychologists we
should treat human experience as that
reality and so the reality for you from
a phenomenological perspective is
everything you experience they assume
everything you experience is real and
they also assume that you can't actually
get more real than that and so your
consciousness whatever that is is real
and your dreams are real and your
emotions are real and your pain is real
which is a really useful thing to think
if you want to make sure that you're not
going to hurt people you know you kind
of have to think that maybe faint pain
should be treated as a fundamental
reality instead of as an epiphenomena of
some material substrate and so that's
their first perspective and they took
that from Heidegger because Heidegger
thought that Western philosophy had gone
got off on the wrong track
you know three thousand years ago
because we didn't really concentrate on
being itself as the fundamental mystery
and so the fundamental mystery is why
the hell is there anything and since
there is something experiential being
what are its fundamental elements and so
that's the phenomenological stance it's
it's completely it's not the same as a
scientific approach because it starts
with a different presupposition you know
the scientific presupposition roughly
speaking is that things are the
objectively real elements of things are
the most real elements and there's no
sense complaining about that because
it's a approach that works tremendously
well for many many things including
making hydrogen bonds for example but
it's also reasonable to think that well
it might not be the it might not be the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
and maybe you could also suspect that
the fact that we can manufacture
hydrogen bonds also might indicate that
there's something a trifle off with our
fundamental belief systems scientific
though they may be and that was
certainly something that concerned
Heidegger even though he got all tangled
up with the Nazis so the phenomenologist
were trying to take apart experience as
such and they made some some hypotheses
and then some observations so the first
is that we're going to assume that your
experience like experience itself is
real now
you just because dreams are real and
pain is real doesn't mean and like
objects that we can all perceive are
real doesn't mean you should put them
all in the same category like my dreams
are not in the same category of reality
as this table because you don't have
access to my dreams and you have access
to the table but that doesn't mean that
my dreams in my pains and my emotions
aren't real they're real
so that's the first now you should note
that this is a this is a proposition
what they're saying is let's act as if
that's true and then work from those
premises and see what happens see where
we can get with it and that that's
that's a perfectly reasonable thing to
do because at the bottom of a theory you
also have you always have to put an
assumption because otherwise your theory
would be a hundred percent right and
would cover everything and it doesn't so
you have to throw an assumption
somewhere in there at the bottom and say
okay we're not we're not questioning
that that's the starting point so and it
you have to do that because you're
ignorant you don't have a full theory so
they don't like the idea that mind can
be reduced to matter they're not playing
that game they're not playing that the
game that the subject is only up a
phenomenal and the object is real they
don't playing that game either and it's
partly because as boss says without a
subject nothing at all would exist to
confront objects and to imagine them as
such true this implies that every object
everything objective is merely objective
in being merely objective eyes by the
subject is the most subjective thing
possible it's a radical claim you know
but here's here's something to think
about when I look at that coke can you
might say I perceive the object and then
I make inferences about its use and then
I evaluate it and then I use it and you
know that is not actually what you do in
fact it's not obvious at all that what
you perceive are objects and if you
think about it well people weren't
perceiving scientific objects until like
1500 AD or 1450 so there was no
objective object before then so
obviously whatever we were perceiving
was not precisely that because we would
have been scientists right off the bat
George Kelly claimed that people were
natural scientists you know that we're
always investigating hypotheses and
trying to disprove them and so on and
it's an interesting theory and that it's
right in a sense but fundamentally it's
wrong
we are not natural scientists were
natural engineers and when we look at
the world we don't see objects and then
in further use what we actually see is
the use so for example when I look at
that coke can
my visual system activates my motor
cortex directly it can do that without
me seeing the damn can consciously to
some degree because there are people
with blind sight I've told you about
those people they say they can't see but
if you ask them which hand you have held
up they can tell you so they might not
be able to see but they can map patterns
from their visual system onto their
motor output you know and that's
basically what Piaget said we do when we
deal with the world
we're embodied creatures you know and so
what we see when we look around aren't
objects there are things we can use and
things that get in our way
you know and that's the theory that was
derived originally from JJ Gibson who
wrote a great book on that called the
visual approach to the ecological
ecological approach to visual perception
and his science is a brand of pragmatism
and the pragmatist basically claimed
that you know things including theories
and perceptions have a limited range of
truth and the truth that that the
limited range of truth is determined by
the match between your actions and
outcome so I think this is a coke cat is
that what it is
no but it's good enough for me if I want
to drink a bit of coke out of it god
only knows what it is you know if you go
into communist China and you start
advertising these things then what are
they because this thing tells a story
right what's the story like really do
you need Coca Cola no it's like it's a
bit of frippery you know it's a bit of
it's not necessary luxury it's not even
very good for you but it's kind of fuzzy
and it's sweet and you get to buy it and
why is that because no matter how stupid
you
in your nutrition choices as far as our
society goes you have the right to
poison yourself in whatever way you
think best befits you and so when you
send this little coke can off to
Communist China this thing screams
stupid individuality all over and god
only knows how it undermines the state
you know and if you don't if you're not
thinking about that you're not thinking
think about what happens when we export
cars what does a car say it says hey you
can go wherever you want whenever you
want you don't have to tell anybody at
all and you can do it in a really
dangerous high-speed manner it's like
you want a political statement wrap it
up in metal and ship that thing off and
everybody goes oh I really like to have
one of those it's like poof communism
disappears with that you know that
there's nothing that says individuality
and capitalism like a personal
automobile you know you even get to
pollute the atmosphere and ruin the
planet with the damn thing but you know
if you have to drive to the corner store
and pick up your damn coke it's like to
hell with the atmosphere